hey guys today i am here with my sister
eva and she is going to give a chicken
coop tour
how long have you been a chicken mom
did you have the ducks then too yeah and
could you show me
why that the light looks so creepy
at night
okay we'll turn off the heating in your
room next well i don't know what it is
i'm just telling you it looks creepy
this is the chicken coop it used to be
like a place
area oh lord oh this is so gross okay
really oh wow it's you got rid of the
ceiling in here i haven't been in here
in years of ceiling like eight years ago
okay so give us a tour okay well this is
the chicken coop
they don't lay eggs yet they're too
young but we have like the nesting boxes
where they're supposed to
okay it has a lot of feathers in there
then we have roosting bars where they
sit on
and they can grab one hold on
yeah no not happening um
and then up there we just have like a
heat area if they want heat they can
stand up there
okay and then we have another bar and
then we have the food
and water here in this big trash can
more food you anything to say about the
chickens
they're very stupid they tend to follow
me around
like i'm their mother but the thing is
that i could be anybody trying to come
kill them
um oh wait get show the outside eva
the what's in the back evo what's back
here um this is where the doors
the chicken coop is supposed to open if
we're having troubles with it it's
supposed to be automatic and open in the
morning and
close it the night but we're having
troubles with that so currently
let them out do that okay